oui
je voulais dire
à
et
e
à
nous
oui
il
ce qui me plaît dans le travail de
bertrand c'est qu'il essaye de créer une
ambiance je pense que c'est un cinéaste
de l'ambiance et il fallait donner cette
ambiance saint laurent qui est quand
même un clan et c'était un clan à la
fois dans le faux rythme mais je crois
que madame munoz c'était la droiture et
le devoir et la rigueur il fallait que
j'essaye d'incarner ça et une dévotion
absolue face à saint laurent christe
quoi quels rapports vous avez vous avec
avec votre personnage dans que ce serait
très prétentieux de faire une analogie
en revanche quand on fait un film comme
ça on est obligé de la faire au moins
pour soi même et de se dire un moment il
sent le rance et moi quoi sinon sinon on
reste trop loin du film pour pour
s'approcher au maximum il faut il faut
il faut il faut le ressentir après moi
je peux me retrouver dans pas mal
d'aspects voulez mais ils sont alors en
a c'est compliqué oui forcément mais je
laime avec des critiques voilà jeu mais
oui bien sûr je vais tout ce qui faisait
lors de l'atelier qu'on pouvait de prime
abord assimilé à de la débauche ou à
quelque chose d'assez d' assez sombre
assez glauque et est finalement est
devenue pour moi les moments de grâce de
vie de lumière et l'atelier le travail
et étaient plus quelque chose qui était
du domaine
enfin quelque chose de carcéral où il
était infantilisante surveiller et donc
voilà c'est là je pense vraiment où le
personnage et le film s'est déployée
c'est quand on a commencé à attaquer ces
séquences de nuit qui sont devenus pour
moi les les scènes de lumière mois ainsi
que mes producteurs et tous les gens
qu'on travaille et nous avons descendu
une seule chose c'est la liberté de
faire le film que nous avions envie de
faire
donc c'est vrai que pour être libre
parfois il faut faire les choses un
petit peu dans son coin mais je pense
qu'on est tous ceux très fier d'être
arrivé à ce résultat
et s'il ya eu des problèmes par le passé
n'ont aucunement empêché le film dead
qui on a envie qu'il soit c'est vraiment
une idée de scénario et c'est quelque
chose que tu arrives et extrêmement tôt
l'idée que
la voix reste la même mais le corps
change totalement et il nous est apparu
évident qu'il n'y avait qu'une seule
personne pour pour faire ça comme ça
pour représenter ça pour montrer ça sans
trop d'artifices c'était hellmuth bergen
après à la question comment s'est passé
le tournage jeu
le tournage très bien l'avant tournage
plus difficile mais je pense que quand
il est arrivé sur le plateau et qu'il a
vu qu' il y avait une caméra du 35 mm d
beaucoup d'éclairage que c'était très
sophistiqué est ce que ça lui rappelait
des souvenirs austère mais tout d'un
coup il est vraiment rentré dans le dans
le film immédiatement c'était une
expérience qui pour moi pouvait susciter
beaucoup de craintes d'angoise
j'ai eu vraiment peur à un moment et et
déjà j'ai trouvé énormément de confiance
dans le scénario sur lequel je savais
qu'on pouvait vraiment content et j'ai
découvert ce scénario en me disant que
voilà j'avais entre les mains quelque
chose de des normes et de très beaux et
d'une certaine façon ça mettait la barre
encore plus haut et ça rajoute est une
angoisse supplémentaires je me demandais
si du coup au tournage on allait réussir
à insuffler quelque chose de nouveau de
supplémentaires si on allait à réussir à
aller au delà du scénario ce qui pour
moi est le but du tournage et voilà j'ai
aussi trouvé énormément de confiance en
bertrand donc je dirais que oui le nom
je suis fier c'est d'être arrivé au bout
de cette expérience ce qui n'était pas
forcément évident au départ vu vu dans
l'état de de peur dans lequel j'étais